she wants us to guess
well beyond playing the piano uh
something cool she can do
she wants you to all guess how many
languages she can speak
now we all before we ever come on stage
everyone put into
the stage chat how many uh how many
languages you think she could speak
we have 5 42
7 7 thirteen
four seven five five twelve we had to
like the closest about going over i
think
all right a bunch of zero dan thank you
negative one
please welcome sonia
hi everyone how are you how's how are
you jared
and um yeah i i i'm really glad to be
here
and actually i am um
how many languages ah how many languages
uh four four not someone there earlier
did five i know um she beat me
but anyway if you're here in princeton i
live in princeton by the way
jared i don't know if you uh know that
but i
live in princeton so anyway um yeah
hey good morning everyone and today i
will be
talking about automated machine learning
and
actually i will be uh taking you to the
technology behind
automated machine learning from the work
and approach
done by one of our distinguished
scientists uh
dr nikolai fuji from microsoft research
so um automated machine
learning has been gaining a lot of
popularity
in the ai community among data
scientists in recent times
and it aims to automate the process of
applying machine learning to
real world problems and of course the
respective data sets that it uses
now by automating the selection
and tuning off machine learning
pipelines
it's needless to say that it will be
able to accelerate
data scientists productivity no matter
what level
you are now let's take a look back
at what this process entails to optimize
a machine learning pipeline a data
scientist must find
the optimal combination of data
pre-processing steps the learning
algorithms and hyper parameter
settings for the data set to maximize
accuracy
so over the years these techniques have
been
built to automate actually two
particular tasks
that's of model selection
and hyper parameter tuning that means
finding the best performing statistical
models for a given problem
and the corresponding configurations
without
human intervention so
let's illustrate this by seeing what
exactly does a data scientist
do when he tries to build a model let's
say to predict a car
so we start off with understanding what
features what algorithms and what
parameters are there
and you would think that hey perhaps
maybe the car brand the mileage and the
year of make might be good features
and then let's choose a boosted braden
boosted algorithm
and then um choose couple of parameters
like
the learning rate the batch size number
of nodes if it was a classification
problem
and then guess what you come up with a
very
s a model that's not performing
quite well so what do you do you iterate
again and you add more features choose
another type of algorithm
and then tweak all these parameters that
you have and this
goes on and on and on and this is so
reiterative
time consuming well then you will
probably
get your you know a very good model at
the end
but that was a lot of work
now there are challenges with hyper
parameter selection
so the performance of models really
depend heavily on the hyper parameter
you selected
however the search space to explore this
and evaluate
all possible combinations is also huge
there are also very few very few
possible configurations that are optimal
and so it is really sparse these good
configurations are sparse
and on top it all only a small
section or a small set of hyper
parameter values
end up performing well but the vast
majority
end up performing poorly and there's of
course
you know the resource and time to do
this
is very limited now
i the impetus actually to
to put out or to create uh automated ml
uh by dr fuji was really because of
his experience with this particular gene
editing problem now this gene editing
problem is one of the most complex of
all machine learning problems
so if you are in the life sciences you
probably know what gene editing is but
gene editing is actually the act of
trying to
edit remove alter portions of your gene
your d your genome your dna so that of
course you may want to treat disease on
this one
but this is a very very uh tedious
process and there are 18 billion
combinations of genes and to find the
right locations is
definitely a combinatorial i mean it's
just
a very very huge space not to even think
about
how many hyper parameters were involved
here
and also what kinds of models were the
right models to be chosen
so it was a very very complex problem
and it took
him about six to seven months to just do
this
so that's the reason why he embarked on
this research on
automated machine learning so
um oops
it's just frozen just a second my
machine froze and i had to
hit that thing hard so anyway
um but there are ways right
there are ways to find what are those
optimal machine learning pipelines and
there are several techniques
to do this so the widely known ones are
grid search and random search because
they are very easy
to implement both these techniques frame
the problem
mathematically and so if you consider
the space for all
possible strategies each of them simply
pick several possible hyper parameters
randomly
and try out uh try it out and keep the
most optimal performing ones in a very
alternative fashion however
what happens here is that it's good only
for models with few hyper parameters
and if there are more hyper parameters
and the search search space is bigger
and actually more configurable numbers
the downside here is that it would take
very long to compute this
an alternative for larger models is to
use some metaheuristics
a class of optimization techniques that
use exploration
versus exploitation trade-off in machine
learning theory
and we'll talk about that later as we as
we progress
now let's look at the third one which is
bayesian optimization
so bayesian optimization differs a lot
from random search and grid searching
that it improves the search space
and speed using past performance whether
whereas the other two methods are
uniform
or independent of past evaluation so
with bayesian optimization the
performance of your
past hyper parameters affects the future
decisions but in comparison to random
search and grid search these do not take
into account
past performance when determining new
hyper parameters to evaluate
so bayesian optimization is a much more
efficient
method so looking at this graph let's
see how
how does this work then how does
bayesian optimization work
um so let's say we want to find a set of
hyperparameters that will minimize the
root mean squared error for a random
forest regression model
here the function to compute the root
mean squared error arm is e
is actually called the let's say the
objective function
now if we want to know the probability
distribution of this objective function
then we can simply just compute the
gradient descent and find the global
minimum
however since we we really don't know
anything about the distribution of this
rmsc
so we need bayesian optimization to help
decipher
this black box model so what happens is
that
bayesian optimization would build a
probability model
or a surrogate model which is the one
here in
blue of the objective function
and uses it to select hyper parameters
to evaluate
the true objective function
now this true objective functions is a
fixed function
and it's designated by this dotted line
that you see here but we really don't
know this at in the beginning
now if we had unlimited resources as i
mentioned earlier
uh we would be able to have we would be
able to compute all of this
right and we would know the shape of
this function
and all about the rmse scores for all
possible
hyper parameter combinations however
that is quite impossible so
let's say we had a couple of points that
we know
from the true objective function
and now that we have a sample point of
this
objective function how would we decide
what the next
representation or what would be the next
uh
thing or hyper parameter that we could
choose from right
so um using these
sample points we need to build this
surrogate model which is the blue line
um to approximate that uh true objective
function
so we build now we have to build in
order to find that next point right
choose the next point we have to build
an acquisition
function and so the next hyper
parameter of choice is where this
acquisition function is maximized right
down here if you see that
curve with a red dot above it and that's
also called
the e i or the expected improvement
curve so the corresponding
hyperparameter
value and its objective score
represented here where the red dot is
in this next slide is actually the next
sample point to update the surrogate
model now there are still
issues actually there are still issues
with bayesian optimization and machine
learning pipelines because
as i mentioned earlier there are some
constraints of this so
it is still hard to model so what dr
fuji did was that he had
two assumptions that he had to add or to
modify
here so the first assumption or the
first key intuition
was to provide a um
sample to provide sample in
instantiations
of machine learning pipelines which is
going to make the space
discrete and fix those sets of pipelines
ahead of training
so for example you could see here that
maybe you can have a pipeline
considering of the top
5 pca component components
followed by maybe a linear regression or
then you would want to remove outliers
normalize it and then
apply a deep neural net the second
intuition was that
well we can't keep treating all these
data sets as
entirely a new problem let's reason out
across
all data sets they got to be
interrelated so
this was the secret sauce the new
approach then
was to combine collaborative filtering
which is actually a metal learning
strategy together with
bayesian optimization to search an
enormous space of
possible machine learning pipelines
intelligently and
efficiently um it is essentially as you
could see here in the diagram it looks
like a recommender system for
machine learning pipelines and this is
similar how you know
netflix if you guys are netflix uh fans
would recommend movies for users or
watch
or have them watch these movies right um
so automated ml as well would recommend
machine learning
pipelines for data sets so if you look
at the left side we have a matrix that
shows you the various movies
and all the on the top all the users of
these movies each of them have their
ratings
of their preferences if two users
like the same movie in the past it's
more likely that they would choose the
same or similar ones in the future
so the same method was drawn from
uh from this and you could see here that
uh from all the other data sets in the
experiments that were
available on the right hand side uh the
approach is that if
two data sets have the similar results
for a few pipelines
it is likely that the remaining
pipelines will produce
the results that are similar as well
the idea here is that the model now is
trained on millions of data set
characteristics
like the size the number of columns etc
um and that is then
recommended so a algorithm is
recommended
which is the best one and the hyper
parameters that optimizes that
is actually also recommended
now having observed this performance of
different
pipelines and different data sets the
task of predicting
the performance of any of these on on
certain data sets
can be as well called a
matrix uh factorization problem now you
could see also there
is a distribution on the right hand side
and this distribution
is the range of possible scores that you
will get running the pipeline on a
specific
data set and as indicated by the
distributions
shown on the right hand side of the
figures automated machine learning also
takes into consideration
uncertainty thus incorporating
a probabilistic model to determine the
best pipeline to try next
and this approach would allow automated
machine learning to explore
the most promising possibilities
without exhaustive search and converge
on the best pipelines for
the user's data faster than any brute
force
method so let's take a look at this and
how this looks like in animation
so
as this chart runs you can see at the
top
that the accuracy in the y-axis is
improving as pipelines are evaluated
across the x-axis on the bottom
left you would see the meta model
converging on
light colored areas and
we repeat that again light colored areas
representing
high accuracy which is better and on the
bottom right we see the meta model
converging on darker colors representing
the lower
lower uncertainty the green circle is
the best result
seen so far and this is and the x is
actually the next model
that you are trying okay
now to summarize this um
we can put this actually in a
mathematical equation
so in this equation you could see that
the loss the model and the data are
inputs to how the optimism optimizer
um you know um works
and then the labels here below the
equation
represents what the optimizer is
supposed to figure out
so this is the old old way right now if
we added
automated machine learning the equation
changes
in that now automl has to
figure out the best model what is the
best model
and aside from that also
figure out the choices of pre-processing
transformations
so the dimensionality of the options
space here grows rapidly
the big unique approach here and this is
one particular
important concept is that dr fuji was
able to combine
hyper parameter tuning and model
combination
and model selection i'm sorry in the
same
process so this is actually
our research paper that you would see
online please copy that if you can or i
could send you the slides
and um this is actually now live
available in
one of our products it was implemented
in azure machine learning and power bi
and we have these documents available
now i
would have wanted i don't know if i have
any uh two or three more minutes i would
want to show you the product but if i
don't have any more
uh i will be concluding this at this
point and you can go to the green room
in the gr i'm not the green and i'm
sorry the expo boost of um
of microsoft and i will be glad to show
you a demo
of how this works because all you need
here are just a few parameters
your data set and a labeled data set a
few configuration parameters and yes
we generate all sorts of models and the
best models here
as well as the best hyper parameters
so with that um i do i still have the
time
jared or not because i i can still show
a little bit of the product but if not i
can end it here
two minutes two minutes oh my goodness
okay two minutes um just to show
everyone a taste of it so here is the
um this is how it was implemented with
azure machine learning you saw it
yesterday probably in
david's session david smith and you
would
probably if you have an azure
subscription you would go over here to
automated machine learning and you'll be
able to
actually create the models that you wish
um i here have plenty of
models already that i have run so
um let's see um
[Music]
still trying to okay there you go
it's still trying to render the screen
is a little slow i guess it's my
my response time so i have here a lot of
um
uh experiments so these are experiments
and
let's take a look at just one experiment
here
and um i just wanted to show you how
this was run and it generated all these
models right
all these models were auto generated by
um
azure machine learning or automated ml
so automated ml is
inside or part of azure machine learning
and you could see
all of these different combinations of
models
and each of these models are explainable
so there is
integrated explainability and
interpretability and fairness
included within the model so you're able
to do this explain
so with that i will be closing my
presentation
and i hope that you guys can go over the
uh the expo booth of microsoft so i
could show this to you further
thank you great thank you sonia
the automl is so hot right now